Speaker 1: All right. Let's look at a couple other
things that I have for you today. I'm going to
play a clip for you now from what is supposedly
the straight news. I don't mean heterosexual,
by the way. I think when I'm talking about Fox
News, it's important to clarify. Fox News does
this thing where they say, okay, listen, we have
our straight news and we have our opinion. Sure.
The opinion side has a right wing lean because
those are the individuals we have. They are
allowed to give their views and say whatever they
want. But when we do news, when we do straight
news are anchors, they are just doing news.
Now, we all know that that's not true. We know.
We've known for years that that's not true.
One of the techniques that the Fox Straight
News shows will do to do the very same opinion
that the opinion shows do is Tucker Carlson or
Sean HANNITY at night will give some disgusting
opinion about something. And then the next day,
Fox News hard news shows report on the opinion.
As if it is newsworthy, right? So Tucker will go,
Oh, immigrants make our country dirty and poor.
But that's opinion. The next day, the anchor who
doesn't do opinion goes on. Fox News host Tucker
Carlson says that immigrants make our country
dirtier and poorer. Is this true or not? Now we
debate that with one talking head versus another
topic. Okay. So you know that technique. But
Harris Faulkner is a particular Fox News straight
news anchor who is increasingly straight up using
Tucker Carlson and other Fox News hosts disgusting
rhetoric about immigrants to the point that
she's openly using Nazi type rhetoric now on her
program, I guess we call it. Okay. Let's
listen to what she had to say yesterday.
Speaker 5: Caught my eye and ear. Senator,
thank you for being in focus today.
Speaker 2: Yeah, thank you, Harris.
Speaker 5: The fallout over the bombshell report
on the DHS asking for military volunteers to do
chores for people who've shown up at our border,
including picking up the garbage after them. Now,
I've shown you on this very program an exclusive
video that they leave a trail of unspeakable. From
the river's edge. Until they can enter some place
illegally where there are no border patrol, nobody
there to stop them. Some sensors that that are
very, very slow to respond to because there are
so many of them. They make our country look like
what they left. And now our people are going to be
picking up all that trash and all that excrement.
It's in focus.
Speaker 1: Oh, boy. What a hard hitting story.
This is essentially straight up Nazi
style rhetoric that Nazis used about Jews,
which now many of these right wingers are using
about Hispanic immigrants from Central and South
America. They have been building up to this
on Fox News for a long time. Okay. This is
essentially using Tucker Carlson's poorer and
dirtier rhetoric about immigrants. They make
our country look like the crappy place
they left behind, the trash that they
left behind. And now we're going to be going
around picking up their trash and excrement.
This is straight up textbook. What? The type
of stuff that used to be said about Jews. Oh,
they bring disease and they bring filth and
they infect and they get released into the wild,
sort of like animalistic type, dehumanizing
language. And understand that what I showed you
is supposedly, ostensibly not opinion journalism.
That's that's the news hour on Fox News.
It's just overt at this point in time. And so when
we wonder, you know, how can these what we call
primary Fox News viewers, people who primarily get
their news from Fox News, how do they believe so
much stuff that's not true? How do they believe
lies about climate change, the election vaccines,
taxes, the economy, oil, electric vehicles?
How how is it that they believe there's so much
stuff that's not true? It's because they only
watch Fox News or almost only watch Fox News.
They can't tell the difference between news and
opinion and what is a fact and what is an opinion.
And Fox News deliberately makes it difficult.
And by difficult, I mean, you know, like.
An intelligent person would be able to tell the
difference. But Fox doesn't help distinguish
between its opinion and news shows. And this is
the type of stuff you get absolutely disgusting.